today's topic kevin samuels so we did a
live stream with him recently and there
was some really great moments a lot of
people feel that kevin samuels really
dislikes women
all right and that he's he hates them so
i did some research and i found a clip
that i think you guys are going to enjoy
and yeah oh and
he is the hardest strong woman you are
you living an interesting life i mean 34
working in the warehouse what are you
doing is interesting
i mean i like to work out okay
i mean i like this so i like to go out
you know places and visit places and
stuff
you know i don't know you doing this
interesting see i didn't i didn't have
none of that when i was a kid man
i didn't go to my uh proms and nothing
like that and what
and at 34 years old that's your
responsibility to address
nobody's concern but your own no one
cares what you did not have
that's your problem that's it i didn't
have a father that's my problem
everybody got something how tall are you
i'm only five
five just turned around um
i'm overweight working on it okay okay
you got two struggles already you can't
be short and fat
yeah two strikes
that's good i was trying to keep my
straight face during the interview
i could not you already got two
struggles pick one two strikes
about how much do you make a year um
forty
thousand how old are you for almost
so you underemployed too yeah all right
bro
so you so short don't have to worry
about that but your weight and your
money
with your confidence oh
why would the female of the species want
to take your
genes and put them into the next
generation
that's correct sure i mean you're fat
underemployed
and unambitious okay the reason why i'm
laughing
is not because i want to ponder dude
it's because of the way he says and how
blunt it is
it's true though he's not lying about
what he's saying
you know a lot of people put themselves
in disadvantaged positions either
because life is already dealt with
by bad hand like being 5-2 as a man or
whatever
and then they don't do anything to
compensate to help themselves so of
course
life is going to be cruel to you in some
degrees and when he says it it's just
like you're so not
used to hearing that on open platforms
that i could not help myself and i was
dying what i believe he said
is not what he thinks of the person he
doesn't know the person but it's
actually what is
happening out there like when he says
what makes a woman want to take your
genes
and put it out there at the end of the
day it's time to see what he thinks
but that's what the dating world is
that's the whole purpose of the dating
world
yeah but you know you don't know if that
person is nice know whatever i
understand that i get that but all the
people that's me i'm attracted by the
smart
smarts is not something that you see
from afar
you have to sit down to have a
conversation and what attracted you to
sit down
was the looks of was what they saw and
that's not something that's really going
to be appealing to a certain degree
ladies you guys are like employers that
are really sought after all right men
are the employees
now if men doesn't have the criterias or
the credentials
the college level education you're not
even going to give them an interview
there's a lot of people who are fit for
jobs but don't have
the paperwork behind it but you're never
going to know so are you saying they're
like
no we want the most competent people
well based off the criteria that you
have
a lot of those people are going to get
filtered out so that's what it comes
down to when you are a
ugly unattractive short whatever it
might be
if you don't have anything else to try
to elevate your resume you're not even
gonna get through the door
should males like that in the in the
animal world
be able to mate no
at 38 years old is this what you thought
you'd be in life
no and what are you doing about it um
working out no you're looking at your
fat
that's true i'm sorry
i'm sorry
see this is why i have these
conversations because a lot of this
stuff gets
lost in the sauce when women start
talking about women in these red pills
and those other kind of stuff
this ain't got nothing to do with women
see at five foot five five you should be
you should be in shape for you
you have zero confidence um and you're a
quitter
um you're underperforming and you lack
ambition
you need to go enroll in martial arts a
boxing somewhere
and let somebody knock the out of
you
because you don't know who you are
people really translate that as
oh you need to get beat is that what
you're wishing hinting no
but there's something that you have to
understand about martial arts
and taking a punch that teaches you
about life
about not quitting no matter what
happened
no matter about how you get rocked you
get back
on that's what he meant it's about
adversity
you live adult life and you lack
ambition you know one thing
good about martial arts like if you're a
beginner you go in there and you spar or
you do whatever you train you get
humbled all the time
you're getting constantly submitted
you're constantly getting knocked on the
floor like
a safety you're constantly learning new
techniques so it's good it's good for
building character and i think that's
what he's saying about this yeah
but it's funny the fun of what he says
is the delivery funny
uh i kind of disagree with some of the
things you're saying uh okay
how old are you 20. okay why does your
opinion matter
uh everyone's opinion is valid no that
doesn't twenty-year-old
guy who's
he's right you know when you're 19 and
you got these super strong opinions it's
like it's fine there's nothing wrong
with that but
experiences back it up exactly you know
it was just funny the way he said
it and i played this whole thing to one
show you two things one that men do need
a lot of this counseling and this kind
of guidance and two
that there isn't an uneven idea if you
come to ask a man for advice and he
talks to you the same way he talks to
men if he talks to you ladies it doesn't
mean he hates you guys you guys are so
used to men
talking to you with cushions a certain
cell
level of like tone policing that you
assume
direct honesty and bluntness is somehow
an attack on you no
this is how we talk to each other often
times it's not for everyone but if you
come
to ask for advice that's what you're
going to get the military and basic
training and all these things it's not
for everyone which is why they don't
come in your bedroom and tell you to get
up and do push-ups or run at five in the
morning
or to lock stuff around or to make sure
that you're ready for inspection they
don't come to your place
you go to them how does it make sense
for you to go to them and be like
you're mean this is unnecessary why
would you go suck this bus
go ahead i got a story go ahead story
time with freeze you're probably gonna
see that one in the patreon subscribe
yo i think what it really just comes
down to is uh rather than reacting to
these short clips and then trying to
come to an understanding of who someone
is
accept the idea that yo maybe you don't
know maybe these things are taken out of
context
you just seeing a bunch of clips of him
talking to women maybe it's because
that's just what seems to be the most
polarizing that's what people gravitate
to
it doesn't mean that he doesn't talk to
men it doesn't mean that he's not
coaching me he's not telling them what
to do
you just haven't done the research to
know so when you say
he hates women based off of what limited
information clips that were taken
off of his two-hour livestream and you
watched a two-minute clip
so just be mindful of that if you're
gonna look at this clip and tell me he's
not being as savage to these men as he
is the ladies
i would question that so that's what i'm
making this video for
like i said man i think a lot of us
could use some blunt honesty but if you
ain't ready for it
don't ask for it some of y'all are
asking for you not ready for it and then
crying victim afterwards
no so that's all i'm going to say
anything else you want to add
all right tell us what you guys think in
the comments below